HAVE 9/11 STYLE COMMISSION ON
THE PRESIDENTS VIRUS RESPONSE.
WE HAVEN’T FIXED THE PROBLEM
YET.
WOW.
ANYWAY JOINING US AND WITH
REACTION, HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY.
WELL, THAT DIDN’T TAKE LONG.
LET’S HAVE ANOTHER INVESTIGATION
INVESTIGATION.
>> THAT’S ALL THEY WANT TO DO.
WE NEED ADMINISTRATION CAME DOWN
TO BRIEF THE HOUSE ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS, THEY WERE
PREOCCUPIED WITH IMPEACHMENT
INSTEAD OF PROTECTING THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT’S EXACTLY THE ONLY THING
THEY FOCUSED UPON.
AND THEN YOU WATCH NANCY PELOSI.
I WATCHED HER SIT THERE AND SAY
THOSE WORDS, AND IT WAS VERY
UPSETTING TO ME AS AN AMERICAN,
NOT AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL BUT
AS AN AMERICAN.
BECAUSE SHE’S THE ONE WHO FLEW
IN ON SUNDAY.
I WAS IN THAT MEETING.
SHE STOPPED THE RELIEF.
SHE RESTRICTED ANY RELIEF FROM
COMING UNLESS SHE COULD INVOKE
HER LIBERAL WISH LIST INTO
REALITY.
SHE TALKED ABOUT CHANGING
ELECTION LAW.
SHE TALKED ABOUT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
SHE TALKED ABOUT PAYING OFF
PENSIONS.
THIS IS WHY SHE HELD BACK, WHY
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS LOST THEIR
JOBS.
WE JUST GOT THIS TO TRILLION
DOLLAR BILLS THROUGH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SIGNED IT.
YOU’RE WATCHING THINGS COME TO
FRUITION NOW WITH THE
REGULATIONS COMING OUT AND SHE’S
WANTING TO SPEND TRILLIONS MORE
INSTEAD OF LETTING THIS GO TO
WORK AND OUR REAL FOCUS SHOULD
BE ON THE HEALTH THE NATION.
AND ITS CITIZENS.
AND THEN AFTER WE GET THROUGH
THIS IF THERE’S A TARGET AREA,
BUT SHE IS UPSET BECAUSE SHE DID
NOT GET THAT WISH LIST.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE KENNEDY
CENTER AND OTHERS, THE REAL
UPSETTING PART THAT SHE HAS IS
ALL THE THINGS SHE COULDN’T PUT
IN.
REMEMBER WHAT HER NUMBER THREE
SAID.
THIS IS A TIME TO CHANGE THE
SCOPE AND THE DIRECTION OF THIS
COUNTRY INTO THEIR BELIEF, TO
RESTRUCTURE IT, WAS THE ACTUAL
WORDS.
>> Sean: WE SAW WHAT THEY DID
WITH THE MONEY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HOW IT PANS
OUT.
OBVIOUSLY I COULDN’T BELIEVE
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
HURTING WERE FRONT-LINE HOSPITAL
WORKERS.
HOURLY WORKERS THAT ARE
DISPLACED THAT HAVE MORTGAGES
AND RENT SOME CAR PAYMENTS AND
KIDS IN COLLEGE.
AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
BIG BUSINESSES.
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THEIR
WISH LIST IS HERE.
SHOULD WE LET THIS PLAY OUT A
LITTLE BIT?
2.2 TRILLION IS A LOT.
4 TRILLION LOAN GUARANTEES
BACKED BY THE FED IS A LOT ALSO.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU HAVE
HERE.
90% OF THE SPILL WAS ALREADY
DECIDED.
THE CORPORATE WOULD HELP
AMERICANS.
THEY ARE GOING TO A CHECK
DIRECTLY FROM THE GOVERNMENT IF
YOU MAKE $99,000 OR LESS.
IF YOU’RE ON A BLOOD COMING OR
YOU’RE GOING TO GET?
YOU’RE GOING TO GET TAKEN CARE
OF.
$600 MORE PER WEEK FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OUTSIDE OF
WHAT YOUR STATE PROVIDES ABOUT
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
IS THAT YOU STAY ON THE JOB.
SO ANY SMALL BUSINESS OWNER, WE
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE YOU THE
MONEY.
YES IT’S ALONE BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT, IF YOU SPEND THAT MONEY
AND YOU DON’T HAVE TO GO TO
THE SBA, GO TO YOUR LOCAL
BANK, WE GUARANTEE IT.
IF YOU EMPLOY IT ON -- THE
NONEMPLOYEES RENT UTILITIES,
IT’S NO LONGER ALONE.
IT’S A GRANT.
LARGER BUSINESSES OVER 500
EMPLOYEES BE SECURE LOAN BUT WE
GIVE YOU A TAX BENEFIT.
THIS IS ALL FOR TWO MONTHS.
GET THIS ECONOMY BACK GOING TO
WHERE IT WAS BEFORE.